[Music]
steven spielberg had a simple way to
describe poltergeist before it came out
just that it's real scary it's
real scary the oscar-winning director
gave e.t the lowdown on the making of
this horror classic
there's some esoteria in poltergeist but
essentially it's it's a movie about
tightening your stomach muscles and
keeping them there for two hours
you know until something gives you the
movie or stomach
this house is
spielberg broke onto the scene by
terrifying audiences with
jaws and he couldn't help but compare
poltergeist to his very first
blockbuster
it's sort of a land jaws for me it's
it's it's a movie about
ghosts but it's not a send-up who did
you mean who's here
the tv people well the great similarity
is the terror is relentless
and the terror is unseen in both movies
in jaws you see the terror at the end
and of course in poltergeist you also
see the terror at the end both films are
uh you know you can watch like you've
watched jaws and polar guys like this
that's a great way of watching movies i
used to watch films all the time that
when i first saw the thing
when i was a kid spielberg produced and
co-wrote poltergeist
leaving directing duties to toby hooper
director of the texas chainsaw massacre
spielberg was busy in pre-production on
perhaps his most famous movie
e.t the extraterrestrial sometimes what
i think
the motion picture business needs is
just a shot in the arm of new concepts
and
new notions it's really a movie about a
haunting in suburbia both e.t and
poltergeist turned los angeles san
fernando valley into a now iconic
cinema backdrop
[Music]
i love making films in los angeles or in
hollywood i like working here i like
sleeping in my own bed at home and
driving to work in the morning as
opposed to staying at a holiday inn
somewhere in montana
something's funny going on here next
door both movies i was making together
i mean i was cutting poltergeist and
then
cutting e.t only three weeks apart so
it's almost like making two movies
at the same time and i found that was in
a way helpful because it gave me great
objectivity when i was working on
poltergeist i had enormous clarity about
et when i was suddenly involved in et i
had
enormous clarity about poltergeist
they're so different poltergeist is a
scream and e.t is a whisper
and uh and yet they're very broad-based
movies meaning they reach out i think to
all audiences knocking out back-to-back
movies in one year became a habit for
spielberg
even after this grueling schedule took
its toll on the filmmaker
a lot of sleepless nights it's hard to
hold a solid relationship with your
personal life when you're working this
hard i've never worked
harder i don't think essentially the
only real problem was that uh
you can't do everything i keep trying to
wear all the hats and realize only one
or two hats fit
can you only move the headstones you
only
move the headstones poltergeist's
terrifying scenes were all the more
disturbing thanks to its oscar-nominated
visual effects
this thing is growing out of her and
it's getting larger and larger
and it goes breaks up like blowing
a smoke ring apart in the air it has a
lot of reality and it has a lot of
extraordinary special effects in it
i've never sensed anything like it
you know i'm i'm sitting here true to
form talking about epic production value
when in fact you know it's the heart of
the movie that sells the tickets
it's who the people are it's how they
relate to each other and what's the st
it's what the story is about that that
grabs the audience
while jaws made audiences afraid to go
in the water
poltergeist made people afraid of what
dangers might await them in their own
homes i think it's fun people like to
get on a
you know a downhill run and stay there
until they either
win or hit the wall